über jahre werden sie geschnitten und in
form gebracht
alles unikate und wert objekte die in
einer baumschule in norddeutschland auf
ihre besitzer warten
baum maklerin katharina von ehren ist
regelmäßig hier sucht bäume aus die
landschaftsarchitekten für luxuriöse
gärten brauchen heute soll sie eine
große bonsai kiefer finden
diese hier ist fast 30 jahre alt und
rund 15.000 euro wert sie kommt in die
engere auswahl
katharina von ehren durchforstet für
ihre kunden baumschulen in ganz europa
das geschäftsmodell des baum maklers
kommt aus den usa
katharina von ehren hat es nach
deutschland gebracht
die bilder und sagen dass es genau das
was wir ausgesucht haben deswegen
fotografieren wir das auch von
unterschiedlichen seiten
und wenn wir dann das okay bekommen dann
geben wir den befehl des auszugraben und
schicken den lkw booms und die kiefer zu
verladen
für diesen privatgarten in der nähe von
hamburg hat sie die bäume ausgesucht im
auftrag von landschaftsarchitekten
claudia scharf
diese setzt auf das urteil von katharina
von ehren mit der vermittlung von bäumen
hat die maklerin in ihrem ersten
geschäftsjahr fast eine million euro
umsatz gemacht
ehrlich gesagt war ich oft in der
verzweifelten situation dass ich zwar
eine großartige vision hatte aber sie
nicht immer konkret umsetzen konnte
der pflanzenmarkt ist so groß dass ich
ihn in meinem täglichen business gar
nicht allein durchbringen kann bäume als
statussymbole manchmal richtet sich der
fokus auf einer einzelnen pflanze dann
freue ich mich natürlich dass ich meine
altbekannten wieder treffe die hier vor
in den baumschulen gesehen und aus
gebunden hat und die jetzt im garten zu
sehen am richtigen standort so eingefügt
in das gesamte in die gesamte
gartenplanung das ist super zurück in
der baumschule ein chinesischer
hartriegel einer der lieblings bäume der
maklerin ihre auftragsbücher sind so
folgt dass sie nach neuen mitarbeitern
sucht für immer mehr menschen ist ein
explosiver garten eine geldanlage
häusern autos was sie auch immer nehmen
reduziert sich der wert häufig nach der
fertigstellung das ist bei uns ja
eigentlich im gegenteil der fall es wird
er immer wirklich noch ausdrucksstärker
charaktervoller schöner bei
entsprechender pflege und es gibt trends
bäume sind ähnlich wie die architektur
langfristigen moden unterworfen
im moment ist es ganz und rennt wieder
zum etwas malerischen etwas wild
gewachsenen gehört neben den stark
formierten also relativ starke kontraste
mit denen gearbeitet wird und es kommt
natürlich auch immer noch neue gattung
arten sorten das huhn einen garten
klassiker in europa der tour ja auch
lebensform genannt die zypressen art ist
eine beliebte heckenpflanzen hier
wollten die hausbesitzer eigentlich nur
rasen doch dann setzt sich
landschaftsarchitektin claudia scharf
durch katharina von ehren besorgt bäume
die skulpturen gleichen einen kiefer-
und einen wacholder groß bonsai sucht
sie auch ein ganz anderer anspruch hier
soll es immer gleich schicksal und nach
möglichkeit auch immer gleich aussehen
und das schaffen wir mit diesen tollen
form schritt gehörten optimal
der hat natürlich seinen preis bei den
schon fast 50 jahre alt ist und immer
wieder geschnitten und immer wieder
verpflanzt wurde und das stamm so
gewählt wurde und so weit also der mich
zu um die 20.000 noch bis zum herbst
sucht katharina von ehren nach schönen
und ausgefallenen exemplaren in den
baumschulen
dann beginnt die pflanzzeit und die
schützlinge kommen in die obhut ihrer
neuen besitzer